well you started i mean i the likability
factor on you is really high because you
get cash can we search my likability on
the internet well is there where do you
go for that likeability. look at these
roles like todd phillips keeps casting
you like people keep hiring you why is
that
well i think you probably have
experienced directors or
writers who think you're sort of a muse
or someone who's like oh my god i have
this other thing michael and i'm
thinking of you todd was one of those
guys i auditioned for him once what was
that uh first one was road trip and then
also because one of todd's co-writers
was my buddy scott armstrong who i
became friends with too
so sometimes when scott and todd were
writing they would name a character
walsh loosely because i have an every
man quality like you can put me in a
short sleeve shirt and a tie and i look
like i belong there so
uh i think they loosely kept me there
but i would audition for walsh i've
auditioned for walsh
characters characters that are named
yeah
so it wasn't a gimme i had to go in and
then and then my guy in the hangover was
walsh with a v
doctor
which i don't think i had to audition
for but uh yeah so i think todd long
story short i think he just liked me
right away like and also i think he
likes improvisers and he likes
to play with it on set right and so i
was able to do that with him and i think
we had a good you know playfulness on
road trip that is the first time you met
him
i auditioned for him in a room before i
met him yeah and did you impr improvise
in the room i think i took it further i
think i went beyond what was on the page
like the scene continued and he didn't
cut it
so i think that's probably where the
improv happened i didn't feel
emboldened to just like throw the script
away and just improvise the first time i
met him what's it like being on set
and you have the scene
do you know that with a guy like todd
phillips you are improvising a lot of
these guys that hire you they're
expecting matt walsh or matt walsh to
come in and bring something
bring something extra do you feel like
there's a pressure
no i don't i
personally welcome it if it's
if it's what they're looking for i want
collaboration i want to be able to
contribute to the material always i
always have plenty of ideas which i'm
never married to i don't have a big ego
like i have a much better joke put that
away i'm you know i'm
i'm pitching it in a collaborative way
uh always so i love those situations
because when you're tight
you don't
express yourself as well quite honestly
not that i can't do a scripted scene as
scripted but i also like if i understand
the character and the and the
camaraderie or the sort of artistic
is there between you and the director
then you can play in a fun way which i
think gets you a little extra right